here's what would happen if jupiter  swallowed earth  as the earth gets pulled toward jupiter  our planet's velocity would increase  until it reaches 60 kilometers a second  that's 250 times faster than an airplane  so you'll want to hold on tight  there's a serious risk that we could  collide with any of the 79 confirmed  moons orbiting jupiter and if we did  happen to avoid all these moons we would  crash into the gas giant itself  both planets atmospheres would be  compressed rapidly increasing the  temperature and essentially setting the  air on fire  earth is so small that it would burn up  at jupiter's atmosphere this would have  a massive impact on jupiter as the  earth's remains would mix into its  atmosphere so if you ever notice our  planet going off course and heading  toward jupiter  we're in huge trouble because